all right
um
good stuff a lot of Victories but it
hasn't all been uh it hasn't all been
good and there have been some setbacks
and here's one daily wire reports a
federal judge has ruled Friday that a
Tennessee law intended to Shield
children from sexually explicit
performances is unconstitutional U.S
District Judge Thomas Parker said a law
that blocked children from being exposed
to adult Cabaret performances including
sexually explicit drag shows was
unconstitutionally vague and
substantially overbroad
quote there's no question that obscenity
is not protected by the First Amendment
but there is a difference between
material that is obscene in the
vernacular and material that is obscene
under the law Parker wrote simply put no
majority of the Supreme Court has held
that sexually explicit but not obscene
speech receives less protection than
political artistic or scientific speech
Parker was appointed by former president
Donald Trump
said that the law would also allow
discriminatory enforcements
Parker said quote whether some of us may
like it or not the Supreme Court has
interpreted the First Amendment as
protecting speech that is indecent but
not obscene
according to a summary of the law which
was signed by Governor Bill Lee it quote
creates an offense for a person who
engages in an adult Cabaret performance
on public property or in a location
where the adult Cabaret performance
could be viewed by a person who is not
an adult
the definition of adult Cabaret
performance in the law includes male or
female impersonators
so uh
and of course uh
the people responsible for the law
Senate Majority Leader Jack Johnson said
he's disappointed in the ruling he hopes
that Tennessee attorney general would
appeal the decision and uh and the
Attorney General better appeal it's this
is a ridiculous ruling it's absolutely
absurd and this needs to go all the way
to the Supreme Court
you know first it's like we're once
again acting
like we don't understand what the word
obscene means or like there's some sort
of ambig ambiguity here
um there really isn't
and in this case you know it's pretty
specific
you know it bans sexually explicit
performances in front of children
it mentions adult Cabaret performances
like that's that's pretty specific okay
and it's intended to
um
Outlaw a certain kind of performance in
front of kids
and in 99.9 of cases we all know exactly
what that is
so oh we always get hung up in the gray
area well if if this law is put in into
into effect and what about all these
other uh unrelated things that might get
caught up in it
there's not much of that
the the gray area here is very very
small
there's always going to be a gray area
in any law
okay there are always going to be cases
where uh where the enforcement is is a
bit ambiguous that happens with any law
at all
but with this one
um that's extremely Limited
and anything else that gets caught up in
it it's probably for the best anyway
the one year anniversary of Roe v Wade
being overturned is coming up and since
then the left has lost their minds of
course pro-life efforts which are more
important now than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
pro-lifers didn't go away they increased
in number 40 Days for life is changing
hearts and Minds in the most blue
pro-abortion States they've had a record
number of locations since Roe was
overturned they grew in both volunteers
and locations with about 1 million
Volunteers in 1500 cities they hold
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities this success has come with
new unwanted attention from the federal
government and the doj in regards to
free speech as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one is in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in each state
in a post Rural America you can help
them fight the ongoing legal battles of
protecting free speech for their
volunteers including
um Mark the 40 Days for Life volunteer
who had his house raided by the FBI
help them defend free speech by giving a
tax deductible gift of any amount at
fortydaysforlife.com that's
40daysforlife.com
you know it takes a special kind of
company to want to partner with my show
I say a lot of things that make a lot of
people angry and this tends to scare off
advertisers that's why I'm so grateful
to Partners like pure talk who stand
behind me and my show no matter the
consequences they might face Pure Talk
shares my values which is why we've made
them the official cell phone wireless
partner of the daily wire but that's not
the only reason Pure Talk offers the
most Dependable 5G Network in the US I
use it myself their plans are top tier
but at a fraction of the cost of ATT
Verizon or T-Mobile you get unlimited
talk text and unlimited data with a
mobile hotspot for just 55 a month you
vote with how you spend your money so
stop supporting woke wireless companies
that don't support you instead go to
puretalk.com Walsh you'll get great
coverage and save while you're at it you
go to puretalk.com Walsh you'll save an
additional 50 off your month because
they actually value you that's
puretalk.com Walsh puretalk Wireless for
Americans buy Americans
like if if we're looking at a certain
type of performance
and we're asking ourselves
is this too sexually explicit for
children yeah would this also be barred
under this law
well if we have to ask that question to
begin with then probably yeah we should
it should be included
second this is not a law restricting
speech it doesn't say that you can't
engage in these kinds of performances
that's not the law
it just says you can't do it in front of
kids
and so this judge says well there's a
distinction between sexually explicit
and obscene
which I think is an absurd distinction
to begin with and incoherence
but when we're talking about speech that
can be simply banned outright
like maybe that distinction is relevant
but here we're talking about speech that
can be uh that that can be performed
because really these are performances
we're talking about performances in
front of kids
and everyone agrees in principle anyway
that sexually explicit performances
shouldn't be in front of kids shouldn't
be done in front of kids or everyone did
agree with that until about 15 seconds
ago
does it does it have to it does it have
to qualify as obscene and sexually
explicit
why would it
again we're not talking about banning
this outright
which personally wouldn't bother me if
they did
but that's not what the law says
the law is saying okay you wanna you
wanna do that you want to have your
adult Cabaret performance you can do
that you just it can't be in front of
kids is all go do it somewhere where
kids can't see it
is that so difficult is that so hard
no it's the activists and and the the
actual uh you know the people who
support these performances
who are saying well if we can't do it in
front of kids there's no point
you know if you tell us we can't do it
in front of kids you're basically
Banning us because we don't even want to
do it at all if we can't do it in front
of kids the whole point is to be in
front of kids
that's apparently what they're saying
which is all the more reason why uh
why this loss is is necessary
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts